not good enough
what is it open for my army my
subscribers my legacy
you've got it all Felix fame 50 million
subscribers the number one YouTube
channel and the best dog of all time
that's seriously questionable and that's
fifty seven million thank you very much
you spend your days trying to design the
perfect pair of headphones you're taking
this too far then you should just leave
just go I don't want you okay why don't
you let goodbye
how's it going everyone funny man bah
I don't know I can do pretty much
anything if you have any subpoenas then
leave it down below but have a good
weekend and I'll see you
pretty soon come back feel her head yeah
look allow what are these oh my God look
around get your racer traction browbeat
- custom-made hoodoo pies and spread
market for you worked with razor to make
these headphones Wow
thank you and good all right
I love you it good oh we're gonna be
super rare we're gonna be a chicken
we're gonna be rich these are gonna sell
like crazy finally acting buy you food
and herds are
[Music]
[Music]
today is very special 70 years ago
before I started making videos I needed
to get a microphone so I spent some of
my last money went out and bought the
racer Carcharias and I used to mean a
ton of my videos you've seen it and now
seven years later I have my very own
Razer headphones designed by me it feels
unreal I never thought something like
this would happen so freaking cool I
love them the design is amazing I'm so
proud of these I I'm so glad I finally
can even wear them because we had to
keep it secret for a long time let's go
that's awesome let's put the mom let's
put them all oh yeah that's dope they
really are something they really stand
out I love the design I'm so I'm so
proud of these oh it's the new ones as
well that doesn't cover your holy
they're more open oh man it's so
comfortable
ah thank you to everyone for supporting
me throughout the years I never thought
something like this would happen
obviously when I started making videos
just looking back this is so unreal I've
always been a huge fan of Razer and what
they do and their design and I'm so part
glad to be part of that and to makes
design something myself as well I got
the Puetz on the side got the brofist on
the side I love it like easily my
favorite headphones ever so yeah if you
want to get these check them out in the
description I think it I think they're
super cool so yeah go buy them I'm just
glad I can finally wear them thank you
guys
squad fam out sister Fister and brofist